أول من يناقش القرار الليلة
سيكون مناظراً حول مشروع IBM ، شكراً لك
[تصفيق]
تحياتي آسف
لقد علمت أنك تحمل الرقم القياسي العالمي
في منافسة المناظرة ضد
البشر ، لكني أظن أنك لم
تناقش مطلقًا أن آلة ما قبل المدرسة عالية الجودة
هي واحدة من أفضل  أدت استثمارات الدولارات العامة
إلى الأطفال الذين يحققون نتائج
أفضل في الاختبارات ولديهم حياة أكثر نجاحًا
من أولئك الذين ليس لديهم نفس الوصول
، أعتقد أننا نعيش في عالم توجد فيه
قيود حقيقية على ما
يمكن للحكومات إنفاق الأموال عليه ، وحتى لو
لم تكن تلك حقيقية.  ومع ذلك ، فإن
ناتاراجان الأيرلندي السياسي الذي يجادل ضد
قرار الحضانة المدعوم القرار أعلن
فائزنا تهانينا لهما ،
أي من المناظرين أثري معرفتك بشكل أفضل ،
دعنا نرى ما
هو هذا الرقم مناظر المشروع بشكل أفضل
يثري معرفة الجمهور على
هذا الجانب ، لذا فإن القليل من  قرار منقسم
[تصفيق]